I'm glad I caught you actually
because there was something I was
wanting to ask you actually and discover
how much we have in common well just
makes me want to ask even more
we don't have anything in common don't
skip ahead
yeah what does wanted to ask you was
something along the lines of
I should have planned this really
oh yeah what I was wanting to ask you
was
you probably wouldn't ever want to
I don't know
fall in love with a boy like me would
you
you're Dominic I don't think so love
oh yeah I know I was thinking no
not even in the future like like when
I'm your age
yeah no I didn't think so
just thought I'd ask in the off chance
you know like being hurt nut
ah there goes that dream
well
I best go over there and do whatever
that thing over there I was going to do
was